hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown general mark
milley the chairman of the joint chiefs
of staff facing calls from some
republicans to resign over allegations
he reached out to china fearing a war in
the final days of the trump
administration fox news senior strategic
analyst and retired four star general
jack keam speaks out in defense of the
nation's top military officer joining
the rundown to detail why
a quinnipiac university poll suggests
president biden's overall approval
rating has slipped to 42 percent
following the u.s withdrawing from
afghanistan fox news sunday host chris
wallace weighs in on the poll and what
it could mean for the president's
economic agenda plus commentary by jimmy
fayla host of fox across america the fox
news rundown is a daily news podcast
where we take a deeper look at the
stories important to you you could
subscribe on your favorite podcast
player by going to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm dana parino i'm juan williams i'm
kennedy and this is the fox news rundown
friday september 17 2021 i'm lisa brady
phone calls are making waves again in
washington only this time it's the joint
chiefs chairman and china thanks to a
new book these calls that the chairman
makes and policy people make with their
counterparts are done to keep them
informed and particularly with
adversaries so they don't misinterpret
something that could lead
to something that could be very
dangerous
i'm chris foster president biden's low
approval rating could hurt his chances
of getting big things done now if biden
were at 70 percent of the polls pushing
the biden agenda would seem like a a
better calculation when he's at 43 not
so much we speak with fox news sunday
host chris wallace and i'm jimmy fella
i've got the final word on the fox news
rundown
[Music]
two phone calls with china in the waning
months of the trump administration are
suddenly getting a lot of attention
after published excerpts from an
upcoming book made it sound like the
joint chiefs chairman offered to give
his chinese counterpart a heads up if
then president trump was preparing to
attack sources tell fox news that's not
true and general mark milley through a
spokesman has issued a written statement
defending the calls as appropriate
reassurance to maintain strategic
stability both president biden and u.s
defense chief lloyd austin offering
public support for milly i have great
confidence in general milly i have
confidence in joel milley but that
hasn't stopped calls for millie's
resignation some republican lawmakers
and former president trump saying as
described in the book it might be
treason in talking
to people in the pentagon i think i have
a grasp on on what took place and it's
it's not only is it not treasonous it's
it's something that they should have
done and there's so much misinformation
out there it is absolutely stunning
general jack keane is a retired
four-star general the chairman of the
institute for the study of war and fox
news senior strategic analyst
this was all initiated by the secretary
of defense
mark esper he saw intelligence
that meant these are my words that the
chinese were getting spun up and
concerned that they could possibly
have a
an incident or a
an unwarranted confrontation with the
united states because the united states
appears to be getting more aggressive
in their rhetoric and also in the
deployment of their forces so when
secretary defense esper saw this he
taught he called it his undersecretary
who's in charge of policy for the
department of defense and he says listen
why don't you send a back channel to the
chinese
and so many so many words these are my
words
he's saying calm the waters with these
guys all right and they got a favorable
response back and then about a week or
so later
uh general milly the chairman of the
joint chiefs
one to contact his counterpart
who they refer to as the chief of
defense but he's a military general
who he has spoken to usually tries to
speak to him once every three or four
months so he's spoken to him many times
that he wanted to make certain that he
understood that the military understood
not just the policy people in china
understood that there's no reason to be
alarmed here so general keane's sources
are offering the same take as the white
house the pentagon and milli himself
that the calls were not secret instead
going through the proper channels with
multiple agencies preparing for and
monitoring them i think it may have been
a video conference but there was 15
people in the room
all
monitoring what millie is saying and
what the chinese are saying through an
interpreter
and then they prepared a memorandum of
that call they don't do transcripts they
don't record the call
and they did a memorandum of it and
shared that
with the interagency so that their
principal leaders who were not in
the room would read
what took place on the call and what the
feedback was
from the chinese that is the system
working about as good in my mind
as it could possibly be because
these calls
that the chairman makes and policy
people make with their counterparts are
done to keep them informed and
particularly with adversaries
so they don't misinterpret something
that could lead to something that could
be very dangerous as to the second call
this is grossly misreported uh in the
media we didn't make the call the
chinese called us
on eight january
they they called us because of what took
place at the capitol on sixth january
they i think the initial conversation
was also with the policy person who
worked for
the acting secretary defense miller
and then uh
millie also got a call and he went
through the same process
once again to prepare for that call that
he did with the with the previous call
and then shared that memorandum uh with
others and also
i had a discussion
i believe it was with uh secretary
pompeo and also the national security
advisor and
uh i i believe that is a reflection of
the system working quite the contrary uh
to what is being said out there and i'm
a little stunned by the fact that after
all of the sensational
reporting that was
done against the trump administration
for four years
and how so much of that
proved not to be true
and now we have sensational reporting
again here
that so many of the people that were
opposed
to that sensational reporting against
president trump
now are are accepting
on face value which
makes no sense to me whatsoever the
biden administration continues to face
questions from both sides of the aisle
about the chaotic exit from afghanistan
and about the president's insistence
that he followed a military consensus
about the withdrawal methods including
giving up bagram air base white house
spokeswoman jensaki on wednesday
pointing back to the trump
administration's deal with the taliban
and defending the current
commander-in-chief he was provided a
range of advice
i'm not going to get into more details
than that but what's important to note
at this point is it's crystal clear that
2500 troops would not have been
sustainable
on the ground it would have been either
increased troops on the ground or
withdraw troops on the ground the
president has said none of his military
advisers recommended keeping 2500 troops
on the ground for stability but sources
are telling fox news that former
commander of u.s forces in afghanistan
army general austin scott miller has
told lawmakers he did recommend that
while warning that a taliban takeover
could happen much more quickly than
expected what general miller in full
disclosure i know very well i've talked
to him many many times over the past
number of years that he served with
him and i've been in contact with him
since he left afghanistan the testimony
he provided
to the senate armed services committee
is something
that i know for a fact
is that he recommended along with
general mckenzie the central command
commander along with general milley
chairman of joint chiefs and the
secretary of defense
that we should not withdraw our forces
from afghanistan
because it will invite and incentivize
the taliban takeover
you can argue about what the time frame
is here
but nonetheless the taliban will take
over
and american security will be threatened
once again
so yeah the president
biden was in had all of that information
even though
we've seen him publicly say well
no one was pushing back on
on the numbers of military we should on
withdrawing the military from there and
then another statement he made well it
was sort of split
uh it wasn't split
in the military channels and it wasn't
split in the intelligence channels
critics of the way afghanistan ended
have also warned that it could hurt u.s
credibility trust with our allies and
embolden our adversaries
do you think that's some of what's
happening with north korea's recent
missile launches for instance
oh unquestionably
north korea sees an opportunity here
to put pressure on biden to get
concessions
sanction really is what they're seeking
economic assistance is the means
uh increased intimidation
from the chinese over taiwan and it'll
result in the same with our allies
you we've already seen the iranians
listen can you imagine how the iranians
feel we've given up seven military bases
and multiple cia bases
on iran's eastern border which is
afghanistan same thing with china
and we're on their board afghanistan is
on their border as well
and now the iranians want to focus on
getting the united states out of iraq
and what have they done well they've
already conducted a drone attack at
irbil
since uh since this with
the debacle involving this withdrawal
i can tell you from
from a source who
american source journalist pull a
surprise winner who just got back from
ukraine
told me that the ukrainians
she was at a conference there and
ukrainians are literally
up in arms over this thing in terms of
their concern about the united states
because they're dealing with russia and
they believe russia absolutely is going
to put more pressure on them and so yes
our allies have have real concerns and
remember
i mean we have been so critical of the
europeans at times not standing up to
support the united states
and the united states is always doing
all the heavy lifting around the world
and the europeans wanted to stay in
afghanistan
and their contribution was seven to
eight thousand the united states
contribution was 2500 they wanted to
keep that seven or eight thousand there
why
even though they went there
because the united states was attacked
they wanted to protect their own
national security they knew full well
that if an al qaeda epicenter formed
again
or an isis epicenter who was able to
form in afghanistan
that they would be attacked as well as
the united states
on wednesday president biden announced a
new trilateral security pact with the uk
and australia known as august for short
calling it part of an effort to update
alliances this initiative is about
making sure that each of us has a modern
capability
the most modern capabilities we need to
maneuver and defend against rapidly
evolving threats especially the threat
from china which swiftly criticized what
it called cold war mentality the goal of
the pact is better sharing of defense
capabilities including nuclear-powered
submarines for australia i absolutely
endorse that and yes that is a very good
thing we have to do more
things like that what we're trying to do
here with china
we know china is going to exist we know
there
at least for the the near future they
will continue to have a robust economy
although i think they're going to face
some eventual headwinds
and we know we have to deter their
aggression
and their ambition to dominate the
region and and the world writ large
we don't want
a military conflict
but we we do have to invest in
deterrence and
your question is an example
of the investment in that deterrence
by giving australia enhanced military
capability so when china looks at
well
it's time finally to take charge and and
take charge of taiwan
and uh bring them finally into the
family
whether they like it or not and use
military force when they
thinking about that decision we always
want them to come to the conclusion
that doing something like that
will impose far too much cost and risk
on us in doing it and will take us away
from our overall ambition
in terms of the kind of status we want
to achieve in the world because the
confrontation
with the united states and our allies
will take president xi and his regime
all
off
any of the strategic ambitions that
they're trying to achieve it'll be a
major setback for them
retired four star general jack keane
chairman of the institute for the study
of war and fox news senior strategic
analyst we are always thankful for your
time
yeah great talking alisa thank you so
much
[Music]
this is jimmy fallon with your fox news
commentary coming up
looking at the last 14 presidents the
one with the highest approval rating at
this point mid-september of year one was
george w bush about 82 percent approval
he got a bump from the patriotism and
unity after the 9 11 attacks
and the people who knocked these
buildings down
will hear all of us soon
the statistics website 538.com has
president kennedy's approval rating
second highest at this point followed by
truman eisenhower and johnson at the
bottom of the list my administration has
brought profound change to washington
donald trump at about 39 percent tied
for 13th place out of the 14 gerald ford
and joe biden he's got an average 46
approval rating right now lower in some
polls and slipping since he took office
that could get in the way of his
economic agenda a lot of democrats are
going to have to make some very tough
choices in the next month chris wallace
is the host of fox news sunday you've
got the infrastructure bill you've got
this huge three and a half trillion
dollar tax and spending bill raising the
debt limit there are a lot of democrats
who are going to have to take risky
political positions to try to push the
biden agenda now if biden were at 70 in
the polls pushing the biden agenda would
seem like a a better calculation when
he's at 43
not so much so it does have an impact
and as you get closer to the midterms it
has even more of an impact as to how you
know whether you want to follow your
leader or whether you want to put some
distance yeah
uh to that end the spending bills uh
president biden sat down with joe
manchin and christian cinema these two
moderates who are sort of getting in the
progressives way they don't want to
spend that much money he basically said
look what do you want and what do they
want
well we don't know
they didn't say we know
excuse me in the case of uh
uh up mansion because he did an op-ed
piece the other day uh he wants a lot
less money i mean he's talking
i mean it's so it sounds so funny as i
was about to say it to say this is a lot
less money because it's a humongous
amount of money he's 16 million dollars
one one to one and a half trillion
dollars but you know which is huge money
even in washington but it's a lot less
it's half or even less than half of
three and a half trillion dollars
you know my guess is
that democrats
i don't know i i guess at this point i
still think that they will pass a big
tax and spending bill because if they
don't
you know with with control of the house
and the senate is tenuous as it is and
and the democratic president i think
it's disastrous for them i mean if you
will if you put them in charge
and they don't come through
i i just think it craters your chances
in the midterms but do i think it's
going to be three and a half trillion
dollars absolutely not it'll be you know
i think it'll be south of two trillion
yeah it looks like they're clearly
really they want to get something done
nancy pelosi house speaker nancy pelosi
says they're going to do what they call
pre-conferencing on the bigger bill
they're going to work with senate
leadership to make sure that whatever
she gets passed can also get through the
senate they want to try to have it
almost pre-approved
yeah well i mean the point is and this
has happened in the past when you've got
a democratic house in a democratic
senate is the house is more liberal and
sometimes they will pass bigger packages
with more liberal things which puts
moderates in this in a spot now they
might be willing to be in the spot if it
then becomes law but to have it then
taken out by the more moderate senate
really is a you know you you you have a
vote you don't want to defend and you
don't even get the benefit of the bill
that you can go back to your
constituents and say well i gave you
this so that that's uh that's something
they don't want to do so
pre-conferencing is basically saying
let's let's work out what can pass both
houses so we don't pass a bunch of stuff
in the house that you're going to take
out of the senate anyway uh president
biden says that
he has complete uh confidence in his
joint chiefs chairman general mark
milley uh the story came out in this new
bob woodward book that millie called his
chinese counterpart late in the trump
presidency to say
to issue some reassurances that there
wasn't going to be a military attack
there are some republicans saying look
he should resign
no he said look i didn't do anything
wrong or even out of the ordinary here
what's your take on it i have to say i
don't understand
why this is such a big deal if
we were had any intention of attacking
china then what millie
did which is basically to say hey we're
not we're not going to attack you now
what you know
uh would be outrageous it would be
treasonous and you know he should be
fired and brought up on charges but we
had no intention of attacking china
there was no reason to attack china the
only reason
that that he called was
supposedly reportedly because they were
getting intel at the pentagon that china
was worried by the instability in the
trump administration and worried
that uh that president trump might
launch an attack against china to try to
deflect and maybe find some way to stay
in power
obviously that wasn't true
but if the chinese believed it that's
dangerous because then there's the
possibility they're going to take some
action to preempt the action they're
worried you're going to take people at
the pentagon are telling us our
colleague jennifer griffin at the
pentagon that looked what the calls were
made but it was no secret
and um and the book is mischaracterizing
this as saying millie was concerned
uh that trump was unstable and might
attack when when in fact it was the
chinese that were worried not millie
right exactly although although having
said that i think there is some
indication
because of another uh part of the
woodward costa book that millie was
concerned about about trump being
unstable and that's when he kind of
didn't insert himself into the nuclear
launch procedure but basically talk to
the people who are part of it because it
goes from the president to the secretary
of defense to other people it doesn't go
through with the chain of command
through the chairman of the joint chiefs
just to say hey look let's keep our
procedures in place
uh remember this is in january
sixth or in the immediate aftermath uh
we had just had the attack on the
capitol there were people who believed
and i think millie was one of them that
uh that trump had played a role in that
insurrection i will say this one thing
critical of millie uh i haven't read the
woodward book yet but
i have read several of the other books
about the final days and there's a lot
of quoting of nilly not not that he
talked to the reporters but he talked to
somebody who talked to the reporters and
how outraged he was by the the clearing
of uh
of of you know the what lafayette square
and the photo op in front of saint
john's church back in the summer of 2020
and a number of things and i i think
that for
a chairman of the joint chiefs to get
that out there in terms of political
comments
is a mistake we've got this rally
justice for j6 they're calling it
january 6. you talked about the right at
the capitol
um capitol police want to be ready for
anything that may happen are you hearing
this is going to be a well attended
thing a big deal is there a lot of
is there a lot of concern in the capital
well there's enough concern that they
put those fences up into the seven foot
fences up around the entire capital
again
generally speaking because it's been so
promoted in advance people think that it
isn't going to go off the the tracks and
become a violent
uh
exercise uh and thankfully the the
house and senate will be out so it's not
like our lawmakers will be in any danger
but you know the january 6 happened and
there so obviously there is concern
about about this you know to be honest
i'm not going downtown uh you know why
why why would you want to you know there
is the possibility but there was a story
i guess was monday that somebody was
arrested and remember it only takes a
few people to do something crazy or one
person that somebody was arrested uh
parked in a pickup truck outside the dnc
headquarters with some knives and
bayonets and machetes in his in his in
his uh cab of his car a truck and saying
that he was on patrol so you know
there's always concern when you've got
something like this
yeah i guess if you're
if you live in dc proper it might not be
a bad day to kind of lay low um chris
one more the california recall amounted
to i don't know with almost 300 million
bucks worth of nothing gavin newsom is
still governor today
now he hammered this whole process
as trumpism may have defeated trump but
trumpism is not dead in this country
the big lie
january 6 insurrection all the voting
suppression efforts that are happening
all across this country is that the
democratic playbook at the moment
well it particularly works in a state
like california where democrats out
register republicans two to one you know
in a state that's more evenly split uh
playing the trump card might not be as
effective uh
the fact is there are legitimate reasons
beyond donald trump to to have questions
about gavin newsom uh you know there's
obviously the the managing of the forest
fires not to say it's his fault uh the
way that covid
and
mitigation has been managed you've got
uh you know this just terrible homeless
problem a real epidemic in some of the
major cities particularly los angeles
you know there are reasons to to
not be crazy about gavin newsom i got to
say and i know it's a tradition in the
west
you know our politics is
is polarizing enough i'm not sure if i
how i feel about the recall situation i
haven't thought about it a lot and i
haven't studied it in depth but you know
we give people four years to be in
office if they if if they then have to
look after two years or three years you
know there's something to be said for
stable terms people have and as you say
it ended up being what 30 million
dollars worth of nothing 300 million
dollars
for 300 dollars i'm sorry i had a zero i
i just wonder whether or not this is
really
what we need in our country well since
you brought it up i just would i have
thought a bit about the california
recall never lived there but the whole
process to me seems kind of
janky now
in effect if
50 percent of the people vote for the
recall
newsome's out
and then you split up all the other
people so somebody with
20 support can end up being governor
to gavin newsom's 49 of support
if you're gonna do it do it put
everybody on the ballot including
newsome
uh
well i i i guess the question that's an
absolutely legitimate criticism and fair
criticism i'm just not sure that we need
more politics and politics i feel like
there's too much politics in politics
and you know let's
you elect somebody give them for you i
mean can you imagine if we had a recall
for president you know and right now joe
biden's at what 43
in in support you know i guess he'd be
he might be recalled it it's uh
i don't know i
don't think you're right politics for a
living but i sometimes i think wow we
got too much going on here
yeah two that would be too much of a i
don't know if it's a good thing for you
to cover um
uh the book's doing great i looked it up
uh you're number two on amazon number
two on uh new york times countdown bin
laden so congratulations gonna be happy
with that
thank you yes uh although you know what
there's a number
ahead of number two
which is number one there is and so uh i
would encourage all our listeners let me
just say i i don't know if i should even
be saying this or not but i got an email
from bill mcraven who was the architect
of the whole raid the uh the the
commander of joint special operations
command and he said to me that this was
the definitive book on the bin laden
raid so i am just thrilled at that and
you know that's better than any listing
on any any booklets but you know
having that from bill mcraven and being
number one would be pretty cool too it's
a history thriller i promise you you
start reading this book you won't be
able to put it down
author
nearly best-selling author i think you
have been in the past though uh chris
wallace also host of fox news sunday of
course chris thanks a lot
thank you chris
jason in the house the jason chaffetz
podcast dive deeper than the headlines
in the party lines as i take on american
life politics and entertainment
subscribe now on fox foxnewspodcast.com
or wherever you download podcasts
subscribe to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
lawrence brooks recently had quite a
unique birthday party it included a
parade of jeeps a performance by the
victory bells entertainment from new
orleans musicians and even greetings
from louisiana governor john bel edwards
lawrence was marking his 112 birthday
and is the oldest living world war ii
veteran in the u.s
the event was a drive-by event due to
the pandemic hosted by the national
world war ii museum which is located in
new orleans
lawrence was born in norwood louisiana
in 1909 and has lived in new orleans
since 1929 drafted in 1940 he was a
private in the army's mostly black 91st
engineer battalion a unit that was
stationed in new guinea and the
philippines and built infrastructure
such as bridges roads and airstrips
after an honorable discharge he returned
home in 1945 and went on to have five
children and five step children 13
grandchildren and 22 great-grandchildren
thank you for your service sir and happy
birthday tonya jay powers fox news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
jimmy fala
what's on your mind i'm jimmy fella so
time magazine named prince harry and
meghan markle to its list of most
influential people this is actually a
good choice because every time i see
them on tv it influences me to change
the channel people are criticizing time
because the cover photo appears to be
heavily airbrushed but i'm not going to
knock them for the touch-up paint
because lord knows i'm not winning any
beauty contests anytime soon what really
bothers me is how publications like time
always airbrush harry and megan's
contributions to society as if they're
making any difference whatsoever when in
truth they're nothing more than whiny
and titled woe is me spoiled brats harry
likes to lecture everyone about climate
change but the guy's constantly flying
around the world in a private jet this
is like telling someone they're in a
snow smoking section as you light up a
cigar as for megan when she's not busy
doing interviews with oprah about how
she's oppressed and she just wants her
privacy she's cashing a 25 million
dollar check from spotify to do a
podcast and oh yeah she's getting paid
tens of millions to broadcast her life
on netflix too i honestly don't even
know who else made the top 100 but if i
were them i wouldn't get too excited
because whoever was in charge of the
rankings clearly screwed up royally i'm
jimmy fallon
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown
stay up to date by subscribing to this
podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network
subscribe and listen to the trey gowdy
podcast former federal prosecutor and
four-term u.s congressman from south
carolina brings you a one-of-a-kind
podcast subscribe and listen now by
going to foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes